Death is a constant presence in Game of Thrones,
and the show made it very clear very early
on that it can come for even the most vital
characters.
With the final season looming, no one is safe,
and the battlefields of Westeros will be very
bloody indeed by the series finale.
Let's get the biggest one out of the way first.
Cersei Lannister, the current holder of the
Iron Throne, will likely not survive the show.
After all, the show loves to deliver on key
fan-anticipated moments, especially when it
involves revenge:
"When you brought me back to Winterfell, you
told me there's no justice in the world, not
unless we make it.
Thank you for your many lessons, Lord Baelish."
There's more to the story than just offing
a villain, though.
Cersei is now at odds with her brother Jaime,
setting up a situation in which he could be
the one who finally kills her.
The Kingslayer Jaime Lannister could become
The Queenslayer, giving his sister and lover
some poetic justice along the way.
And then, of course, there's that prophecy
Cersei received as a child which told her
a younger queen would take away all she held
dear.
Cersei thought it would be Margaery Tyrell,
but it might actually be Daenerys Targaryen.
Either way, she's surrounded by enemies going
into the final season.
If a single human character is going to kill
Cersei Lannister, it seems quite likely that
her brother and lover Jaime will be the one
to swing the sword.
Jaime's watched Cersei slowly unravel to the
point that her power may now threaten all
of humanity, and he may find the strength
in the final season to end her reign himself.
Cersei is clever, though, and she still has
many resources at her command, including the
chemically altered enforcer that was Gregor
Clegane.
Jaime may kill Cersei, but if he tries, she
will very likely end up being the death of
him as well.
The last time we saw the mysterious Red Woman,
Melisandre told Varys that she was leaving
Westeros for Volantis.
Despite her planned trip abroad, we've got
one very good reason to suspect that Melisandre
and Varys won't make it out alive: she's prophesied
it, and her magic powers means that her words
carry some serious narrative weight:
"I will return, dear spider.
One last time.”
“My lady…”
“I have to die in this strange country.
Just like you."
The real question is who will do the dubious
honor of killing them?
Melisandre is still on Arya's list, while
Varys has made a fair number of enemies in
his time.
Fans are eagerly awaiting one specific moment
in the final season: for Sandor and Gregor
Clegane to finally duel it out to the death
after their twisted adventures.
The season 7 finale only served to stoke this
fire, with the Hound seeming to promise that
the fight was coming:
"Doesn't matter.
That’s not how it ends for you, brother.
You know who's coming for you.
You've always known."
The two brothers are clearly on opposing sides,
and while the real fight is with the army
of the dead, there could still be plenty of
time for a showdown for these two massive
men to kill each other.
Game of Thrones loves to build someone up
only to tear them down.
At the end of season 7, Grey Worm is one of
the characters who seems to be in a prime
position for just such a twist.
He's found love with Missandei, he's found
a leader he can follow in Daenerys, and he
stands at the head of a great army.
He's a leader, a warrior, and a trusted ally
who could prove pivotal in the fight against
the dead.
He's also not going to let the Unsullied go
into battle without standing at the front
lines, and that makes him very vulnerable
indeed.
Technically, Beric Dondarrion might already
be dead, since we last saw him standing on
the Wall just as the Night King brought a
section of it down.
Still, it seems unlikely that the show would
kill him off-camera, so we'll assume he lives
to fight another day.
With that in mind, Beric seems like a character
very likely to sacrifice himself in the final
season, and there's a key storytelling reason
for this.
While beyond the Wall, he made a speech to
Jon about the importance of fighting against
death.
"So what are you fighting for?"
"Life.
Death is the enemy.
The first enemy and the last."
That might just have been a prophecy for what's
coming for Beric, since shortly after this,
his personal resurrector died in battle.
That leaves Beric with seemingly no way back
from his next death.
A warrior's death that actually sticks would
be a fitting end.
Few redemption arcs have come so far so far
as Theon Greyjoy's.
He went from being the would-be lord of Winterfell
to being Ramsay Bolton's mutilated slave to
being a warrior for house Greyjoy once again.
When we last saw him, he was sailing off to
try and rescue his sister Yara from the clutches
of his deceitful uncle.
Theon is determined to right his past wrongs
by saving her and restoring their branch of
the family to power.
What that means for the rest of the great
game is unclear, but for Theon himself it
means he's in a perfect position to pay the
ultimate price.
A hero's sacrifice to save his sister and
the Iron Islands seems like the right way
to go.
Few characters in Game of Thrones have suffered
so long in pursuit of a single thing as Jorah
Mormont.
He's been to hell and back trying to win the
affection of Daenerys Targaryen.
Last season it led him all the way to the
Citadel, where Samwell Tarly performed a painful
and dangerous procedure to rid him of his
greyscale.
Now, cured of the disease that was supposed
to kill him, he has obeyed his queen and returned
to her side for what would seem to be the
last time.
"When I take the seven kingdoms, I need you
by my side."
Jorah's love for and loyalty to Daenerys is
not in question, but his safety certainly
is.
He has placed himself in deadly situations
countless times, and at this point he seems
destined to die in the fight to protect his
beloved khaleesi.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one